ベン・アフレックのことを言っているのです
よね、ちょっと待ってください。これはドーゲン
です。今日は超音速ジェイソンとしても知られるジェイソンが加わりました。
実際、私たちはトリックコミュニティを通じて日本に親切にする前にお互いを知っ
ていました。
私は実際に日本で会うまでお互いを知ってい
ました。私はジェイソンよりも少し長く日本に住んでい
ます。彼のオタクレベルをテストしたいと思います。
これは一種のゲームショー
で行います。 映画の元のタイトルを
ハリウッド映画で表示し、ジェイソンは
正しいガイドを推測する必要があります私がタイトルを
付ける[音楽]ジェイソンは日本の劇場でリリースされたので正しいガイド愛嬌のタイトルを推測する必要
があります
終わりなので、最後に
チャクラのレベルを評価してください。ワイルド
スピード
シリーズは、日本のタイトルの最初の
dブラジルミッションハイギア5
メガマックスのワイルドスピードです。私は実際に
これが3つであることを知っています。 ワイルドスピード
正解は3ワイルドスピード
メガマックスですが、最初のd
ブラジルミッションです。ちなみに激怒7
はスカイミッションナンバー2ティーンエイジ
ミュータントニンジャタートルズと呼ばれ
ています。 カメ
を2匹に落とすことができれば、それでも意味のある夫人にするために何を残すことができますか
。 ハーレーの最終的な答え最終的
な答え正解は2つのミュータントタートルです
私は3番目の難破船を意味します-それはラルフです
それは日本のタイトルパワーアップですラルフ
シュガーラッシュファイナルボス
[音楽]
私たちは眉についてそれを作り
ます正解はシュガーラッシュです
他のゲームの名前4番最終
目的地3大丈夫です日本のタイトル
デスパークラストドゥームファイナルデッドコースター
私はデッドコースターです
特にそれが
すでに3番目の映画にある場合はラストネーム3で行きましょうあなたは入ったような気がし
ます 注文だから最後に怪我を
する正解は3つのファイナルデッド
コースターファイナルファンタジーええええ運命
列車多分私は運命の列車だったかもしれないと思う
トレーニングハァッミッション8
分またはナンバー3リアリティリピート
ミッション8分
ミッションはただの言葉かもしれないと思う
人々は
それがミッションミッションのように聞こえるかもしれませんええ
さあ、お金で行きましょう。
正解は
ミッション8分です。
ちなみにこれは、
ジェイソン
が映画のタイトルにミッションを追加するというトレンドの良い例です。スカイミッションまたは
最後のミッションはケビンコストナーの映画のタイトルです。
ジャッキー
チャン映画のタイトルスパイネクストドアまたはミッション15を殺すかダブルミッションする3日間
アメリカの映画イベント
15のタイトルまたは侵略者のミッション
この6番のタイトルは歓声を上げる
か、3番のチアリーダーが
最後に死んだコスタ
私にとって最もおかしなので、私はナンバーワンの歓声を選ぶつもりです
正解は1つの歓声です
または
頭の中の3番目は通常私は
1つの
小さな声で行きますええしかしそれは
あまりにも理にかなっています大きな声で行きましょう
大きな声大きなもの2番目の大きな
声 正解
は、ちなみに頭の中の3つです。これは、
別のピクサー映画の窓の外にある一般的なスロー文法の典型的な例です
。インクレディブルは日本のタイトル
mrです。 信じられないほどのスーパーパワーまたは3番目の
空飛ぶ家族があなたの思考プロセスを通して私に話し
ます大丈夫家族の
中で彼らの1人だけ
が飛ぶことができる理由を見てみましょう
たった一人が
ミスターです。 スーパーパワーである信じられないほどのmm-hmmナンバー2
スーパーマンスーパーパワー
ええ、それはスーパースーパー
ピープルとスーパーパワーについてであり、私はそれ
が正しい日本の映画の
タイトルがナンバーワンのミスターであるように見えるのが好きではないので大丈夫です。
バスの下で赤ちゃんジャックジャックを通して信じられないほど
[音楽]
暗闇を恐れないでください
ギレルモデルトロ2010オルソは
日本のタイトル
です暗闇の中でグリムゴーストダークフェアリー事
は日本では彼らが避けようとするかもしれないと思います
単語2番目の暗い
妖精
暗い妖精ええ最終的な答え私は
あなたが答えをマークすることができる友人に電話するつもりですあなたは答えが暗すぎるとマークすることができます
非常に良い10番
空手キッド
1番はフェンスをペイントします
オフワックスオンワックスオフそれはとても
大きな部分のようなもので
なければなりませんこれがすべてだと思います
床を砂で磨くだけです私は何を待つのが好きです
が実際にはそれは
私が感じた最高の子供とは呼ばれていません たくさんの
嘘だったとしても、それ自体で十分に設定されて
いたので
、端の壁のスコアシートでこれを無視してください。デンゼルワシントンとライアンレイノルズの
11番の安全な家を考慮に入れます。
家の危険な実行
よくええミシ エスコートミッションでエスコート
は、安全な家のためのミッションの正解は危険です。
私の個人的なお気に入り
のダークネスの軍隊は、1992年
のEvil Dead映画フランチャイズのカルトクラシックで、
日本の映画のタイトルブームスティックです
。 笑い]
ブームスティックは当然の
選択である必要がありますが、私が非常に
自信を持って明白な選択をするたび
に、それは私をすぐに蹴ったので、私は
キャプテンスーパーマーケットに行くつもりです
正解は3人のキャプテンのスーパーマンですなぜ
私は正しいのですか ハリウッド映画のタイトルの
日本語へ
の直接
翻訳の多く
は同じように素晴らしいと言われているので
、この時点で私は
ちなみに、言語の同系交配から疑わしい
翻訳に移行するのが好きで
、他の人はこの
傾向に他の多くの人が気付いているようです 日本の
興味のあるウェブサイトtofugooとrocketnewsの
ようなものです。日本に興味がある場合、または
tofugooとrocketnewsをチェックすることをお勧めします。
クイズの後半日本語への直接
翻訳疑わしい日本語への翻訳
は引き続き
空手キッドを却下した場合の最終成績のスコア次の問題は
12番になります
回復中のセックス中毒者の回復についてロマンチックなコメディを共有してくれてありがとう
私の恋人はセックス中毒の奇妙な
病気です奇妙な病気に行きましょう
正解は3です私の恋人は
再びポイント番号13クラシックにちょうどいいセックス中毒者
ナポレオン
ダイナマイトは日本語訳
スーパーシニア私たち男大統領です
それらがバスマン
と
一緒に行こうというラ変身のオプションなら大丈夫
正解は2です
ロンクを殺すためのライセンスは日本語訳
殺人ライセンス禁止
ライセンス消えたライセンス
殺人ライセンスで行こう 殺人ライセンスを殺すための
ライセンス私はそれがかなり
簡単な翻訳であることを意味します右待って
待ってはい
安全な家は危険でした
その場合私は3番で行くつもりです
正解は3です
サムサッカー2005年の独立した
アメリカのドラマは日本の
翻訳ですサムサッカー
は私の人生の昼夜を問わず成長することはできません
サムサッカー17歳で
私の将来を心配しています
年齢と私の将来を心配して
いる
はい正解は3つです
残り17年私は私の将来について嘘をつきました
なぜ16番のジャージーガールに移動するのか
ベンアフレック主演のコメディードラマ私は
私の父を愛しています私は私の父を愛しています
全世界で最高
ですああ、私たちはベン・アフレックについて話しているということ
ですそうですそして
彼への愛について穏健派に正解
は3つの私の愛です rは病気
です私は私の父を世界で一番愛しているという意味
です117ああ
別のボンド映画YouOnlyLiveTwice
は日本語訳です
ダブルライフダブルオーセブンライフ2回
ダブルオーセブン死ぬ2回
反対の会議に行くのは大丈夫なので
、ダイスを2回使ってみましょう正解は
3つのダブルオーセブンのダイスを2回
拾いました
ミッションリベンジ正解は
196時間です
ええ
ボートナンバーナイトテープビームのポートホールを通して光を押してくださいジョンマルコ[ __ ]
は日本の映画
翻訳カオスでジョンナンバー2ジョン
マルコビッチの穴またはナンバー3
ジョンの次元ナンバー1カオスと
ジョンええええ
正解は2で
行こう
ガイド私は最初
から英語の響きのタイトルを
翻訳しなかったので、
これは日本の元のタイトルでし
た。アメリカの監督
がハリウッドで日本の映画タイプの映画をリリースした場合
、芸者の回顧録は
あえぎのようでした。  amo imuy dayまたはそのよう
なもの
は、アメリカの西洋の聴衆のために翻訳される前に、次の作品の元の名前を見つけようとします
。Resident Evilは
、シリーズ
voハザード悪通りの黙示録ゾーンの元の日本のタイトルです
。
少なくともこれを正しく理解するのは私自身のおかげです。
正解は、
バイオハザードの最後の質問
です。明日のクイズエッジ全体の最後の質問です。トムクルーズ主演の2014年の映画
は、実際に
は、メカスーツとネクタイのような日本のコミックに基づいています。
そして繰り返し続けるのは
、元の日本の疑似英語の
タイトルであり、終わらない死のライブダイ
リピート必要なのは殺すだけです必要なのは
行くことです最終的な答えなしで行きましょうfina
正解は3つ
です。必要なのは私の殺害だけです。本屋
で1つは大丈夫だと実際に見たので、私は
何もしませんでした。それで、クイズは何人正解しました
か。  21に下がる空手キッドを数えない場合は合計22の質問
でした
。また
、上限を20に設定するボーナスも少なくなるため、
20のうち20が満点
になります。  〜4正解アンクル
サム4〜8正解時折
チキンテリヤキ
8〜12正解オタク12〜16正解ウィアブー16〜20正解親日または
21〜22正解ニッカドーズヌ
セージ6パスまたはジェットアルト 日本に
興味のある
友達がいたら
、このビデオのリンクを送って、
チャクラのレベルをテストして
ください。来週の月曜日にまたお会いしましょう。
[音楽
]  君